there are so many fascinating fan
theories about Zootopia like why there
are no fish or cats and dogs in the
movie and what's really going on between
Judy and Nick stay tuned to find out
what the directors have to say about
that you'll be shocked when you see the
deleted scene the directors also confirm
why the antelopes our groundbreaking
Disney characters let's dive into all of
this and more with ten Zootopia fan
theories that make total sense this is
priority number one Judy and Nick are
descendants of Robin Hood and Skippy we
love that when Disney movies exist in
the same universe and there's a fan
theory that Zootopia exists in the same
world as Robin Hood not only that but
Judy and Nick could be descendants of
key characters in that movie Robin Hood
himself and Skippy the bunny even more
exciting is the fact that the
co-directors of Zootopia are on board
with the idea a fan asked them whether
someone who lived in the Zootopia
Universe could go back in time and
discover whether Disney's Robin Hood
existed
the directors responded by saying that
it could have taken place in the Middle
Ages and therefore it was a neat idea
that totally makes sense k-max time
pointed out the similarities between
Robin Hood and Nick lending weight to
the theory that they're related
Nick's thirst for justice and rebellious
nature could have been handed down from
his ancestral brave pioneers who weren't
afraid to think outside the box
when society ridiculed Nick for wanting
a fair setup he turned to shady markets
and dealings to bring more good to the
world that's just like how Robin Hood
took from the rich and gave to the poor
and then there's a fact that these two
Fox characters share an uncanny
resemblance as for Judy and Skippy they
both share Laurel
roots so the theory goes that after the
events of King John's reign Skippy's
family was able to afford land and make
a farm this lasts all the way to the new
world where Judy's family are farmers
Judy also believes in justice and
righting wrongs just like Skippy
although this is just speculation
there's another fan theory that got
explicitly confirmed by the movies
co-director Judy's neighbors are a gay
couple when judy has shown to her
apartment at the Grant's Pangolin Arms
we briefly see her next-door neighbors
they are Bucky and Pronk orcs antler son
Oh hi I'm Judy your new neighbor don't
expect it
Judy soon discovers that they are loud
and argumentative they listen in on
Judy's phone conversation with her
parents after her rough first day at
work and they offer up some pretty rude
comments like telling Judy to turn off
the depressing music and telling her
that tomorrow may be worse
they also yell at each other to shut up
the couple largely went unnoticed but
some fans put forward the theory that
they were in fact Disney's first ever
gay couple the clue was in the credits
where they were listed with the same
double-barrelled surname lawrence antler
s'en and in November 2016 co-director
Jared Busch confirmed on Twitter that
they are indeed a gay married couple he
added that they don't yell at each other
because they're gay they yell because
they're real it was in response to a fan
who asked if he'd ever commented on the
nature of Bucky and Punk's relationship
and Jared plus co-director Byron Howard
actually provided the voices for those
two groundbreaking characters the Zito
pians were created by humans
a fan shared a theory on reddit's but
the animals we see in Zootopia are
actually human animal hybrids and humans
created them there are various ways we
can see this in the movie the Zootopia
n--'s have larger legs than their
presents de cousins they are legs made
for walking uprights
so there must be human DNA present to
make that possible they also have
fingers rather than paws and the females
have two breasts this is another human
trait if you look at rabbits in the wild
they are rodents which means they have
six teats to feed their young again that
points to human DNA this fan
acknowledges that there's a potential
problem with this theory and that's what
we hear in the first trailer for the
movie
it says Zootopia exists in a world where
humans never happened and that is why
Zootopia is a modern civilized world
that is entirely animal however the fan
has an answer to that
this humans never existed line could be
what the government of Zootopia says
because after all how would you feel if
you woke up one day and learned that
dragons created humans that might sound
ridiculous to us but utopians might also
find the idea of humans creating them to
be ridiculous we'll give you even more
fan theories
this potential cover-up stay tuned for
more on that later in our video humans
were overthrown by the Zootopia --nz
another fan theory on reddit also
proposes that the Zootopia ng's were
created by humans but this fan takes the
theory even further by claiming that
Zootopia takes place in a future where
humankind has been overthrown by animals
the theory suggests that humans became
so advanced they decided to create new
mammals with human DNA and these new
mammals got the most beneficial human
traits we're talking things like speech
walking on two legs having opposable
thumbs and having a higher cognitive
function that totally ties in with the
kind of anthropomorphic animals we see
in the movie they have these very human
traits like wearing modern clothing the
theory goes on to suggest that these
advanced animals saw how badly their
wild counterparts were treated they were
disgusted by the way humans behaved
towards wild creatures and so they
revolted against humanity over time the
anthropomorphic animals and wild animals
started to breathe and that's what
created the mixed animals we see in the
movie why there are no cats and dogs
this man theory on reddit can also
explain why there are no cats and dogs
in Zootopia and it links to the mammal
discrimination we see in the movie as
well as the stigma attached to being a
predator after humanity was overthrown a
similar stigma would have existed
towards animals that had previously been
associated with humans we're talking
about all those animals you don't see in
the movie as well as domestic cats and
dogs there are no primates horses or
cows one of those animals have in common
they either look like humans or they
have a symbiotic relationship with
humans for example dogs are our man's
best friend
cats lived in luxury horses had close
relationships with humans
cows relied on humans to harvest their
milk and feed them primates looked like
humans and that's why they don't appear
in Zootopia because they were all
removed by the other species why there
is a corgi in the UK version another
Reddit user also put forward a similar
theory but with a slightly different
angle and it explains why there is in
fact a dog in the UK version of the film
a Corgi to be precise which is the
Queen's favorite dog breed but we'll get
to that soon let's go through the whole
theory first the fan suggests that there
are no cats and dogs into topia because
they actively stood by humanity during
the uprising it's not just that they had
a close relationship with humans but
that they defended humans when the
animals revolted this fan theory gives
the movie a backstory were animals
overthrew humanity and an event called
the Great Purge this fan also has a
response to the fact that the trailer
says Zootopia exists in a world where
humans never existed the answer is that
the rulers of Zootopia didn't want their
brutal past to ruin their present day
peace so they staged a cover-up as for
the dog in the UK version of the movies
the fan responded to that by explaining
that the Corgi would have been the
traitor and what did the Corgi do why
led enemy forces down the secret path to
humanity of course why there are no fish
in Zootopia aquatic mammals are also
conspicuous by their absence although we
see water in the movie we don't see any
underwater life the ocean seems to be
there for recreation for the land living
creatures rather than as a home for
aquatic creatures we see the utopians
using the beaches for fun and there are
leisure boats out on the ocean plus
there doesn't seem to be any method to
transport aquatic life around the
metropolis so where are the aquatic
mammals there's a fan theory that the
mammals that live in the ocean like
whales live in a fish topia instead and
that's because it was just too difficult
logistically for them to live as part of
the metropolis but there's a darker
theory too that suggests there are no
aquatic mammals because it's utopians
just don't care about them at all this
is evidence from their natural history
muzeum not all mammals are represented
it's true that Nick and Judy don't
necessarily see every exhibit during
their time in the museum but there is no
evidence at all that there are any
whales dolphins seals or other
intelligence underwater mammals in the
museum and we learn why Judy first
travels into Zootopia we see polar bears
visiting fish town market and Clark
halibuts these are places that sell
consumable fish not only that but
there's also a place called blubber chef
blubber comes from whales and other
aquatic mammals so that means they eat
them to all those utopia is a society
built on equality they don't value
aquatic life and they even eat other
Judy and Nick's relationship is
deliberately ambiguous the truth behind
Judy and Nick's relationship has had
fans in a study debate ever since the
film came out in March 2016 there are
two main camps one that believes they're
just great friends and one that believes
they're romantically involved the
ambiguity behind their relationship
isn't just a fan of AIDS
the directors left the character's
relationship open to interpretation and
they understand why fans can read it
either way
co-director rich Moore told aw that he
immediately found out that one camp of
fans shipped Judy in net and want them
to get married
these fans even showed the directors
drawings of the characters wedding but
on the other side he's found fans who
strongly believe the characters should
not get married they don't want there to
be a romance they just want Judy Ann
next to be best friends and they're
curious as to why every male and female
couple in a movie has to fall in love
when talking about the spin-off
potential of the movie the directors
revealed they would have to address that
lingering plot point rich Moore admitted
that they would have to take on the
questions of what Nick and Judy's
relationship really is like and he knows
that one camp will be disappointed with
their decision
the directors even had some fun with the
ambiguity in a deleted scene and in that
deleted scene it looks like Nick and
Judy were secretly dating stay tuned for
that Judy and Nick went on to have kids
the fans that ship Judy and Nick have
been playing out the debate with other
fans on Korra one fan explains how it
would be possible for the characters to
get together in a sequel and not only
that how the characters could have
children hold up a minute how would a
rabbit and Fox our children the fan made
an argument in favor of the theory by
citing Disney movie history there have
been other odd couples made up of two
different species the fan gave the
example of the Robin Hood movie and the
strong indication of romantic interests
between the bear Little John and the
chicken lady Kluck Miss Piggy and Kermit
the Frog were also held up as examples
the pair had daydreams about having
children together in a movie not only
that but the fan also pointed out how
animals in real life have bred with
others
sees raccoons can breed with cats dogs
can read with wolves and coyotes horses
can breed with donkeys so it wouldn't be
to beyond the realms of possibility for
Judy and Nick to have kids Judy and Nick
were secretly dating when the movie was
first released a fan created an image on
deviant art showing duty introducing
Nick to her parents as her boyfriend a
fan tweeted the picture to the directors
with the comments we know this team was
deleted and director rich Moore actually
replied with a surprising revelation he
revealed that there actually is a
deleted scene similar to this fan pic
and he promised that they try to include
it on blu-ray true to his word the
deleted scene was included on the film's
DVD and blu-ray release in June of that
year in the deleted scene
Judy brings Nick back to her apartment
only to find her entire family waiting
for her her folks are shocked to see
their daughter with a fox
and her dad assumes Nick is Judy's
boyfriend director rich Moore explained
that the scene got caught because a
different version works better they
wanted a moment where someone could
threaten Judy's ability to become a
police officer but people didn't believe
Judy would give up everything because
her parents told her to go home to the
actual scene in the movie was when
Judy's boss almost candor and Nick comes
to the rescue
so there you have it 10 Zootopia fan
theories that make total sense which one
do you think is most likely and do you
ship Judy and Nick or do you think
they're better off as friends weighed in
with your opinion in the comments
section below thanks for watching make
sure to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one
we'll see you next time
[Music]